Speaker 1: Let's go next to Dan
from Oregon. Dan from Oregon.
Welcome to the program. What's on your mind today?
And Dan, you've got to accept my
invitation to join me here on the show.
All right, Well, looks like we've got no Dan,
Speaker 1: let's go instead to Brian from Ireland.
Brian from Ireland. Welcome to the program.
Speaker 2:
Hey, David. How are you?
Speaker 1: I'm doing well.
Speaker 2: Just before my question, I just wanted
to tell you about a new initiative I launched
is basically an award and it's called the The
Best Way to make Money. But when everyone makes
money to fund themselves, it's bad, right?
Speaker 1: I think the bonus show probably
is deserving of this award.
Speaker 2: Well, you know,
I've got good news for you. Yeah, I'm officially
presenting it to you here, so I guess I couldn't.
Speaker 1: And from such a country as allied
with us as Ireland, I couldn't be more glad.
Speaker 2: Very strong ally indeed.
Speaker 1: Thank you.
Speaker 2: I just wanted to. I'm sorry to some.
You've done so already in a previous show,
but I haven't heard so much. The fact that
the House and the Senate are now divided.
No Republicans with the House and Democrats
with the Senate. And as you've said before.
Republicans are basically just going to be
obstructionist and not allow anything to get
done for the next couple of years.
Speaker 3: Yeah.
Speaker 2: Do you think that based on both your
own opinion and based on historical evidence,
will that be will that be good for the Republicans
electoral chances going forward, or will it be
damaging? Is there is there data on this?
Speaker 1: I don't know that I've seen data
and I don't know that I necessarily have
an answer. I mean, what's your thought?
Speaker 2: Well. Well, I mean, I like to
think it will be bad. I like to think that people
would reward, you know, productive governance and
getting things done for the good of the people.
Speaker 1: But it just doesn't always happen,
you know? And particularly, you know, the other
thing is Republicans have Republicans have really
done something clever, which is they've trained
many of their followers to reward exactly the
opposite of what you and I would reward, like when
they train their followers that, hey, you know,
actually government not doing stuff is good. They
then can get rewarded for obstruction. Right.
They they say, you know, we we have done a really
good job by keeping government small and not doing
anything and not letting Democrats do anything.
They have cultivated a followers for a group of
followers that would agree with that. And so it's
very hard to make these assessments of what would
be seen as good or bad by Republican voters.
Speaker 2: That's true. And often those people
that you're talking about that have been convinced
to vote this way, you know, it's not in their
interest at all. It's such a. It's such a shame.
Speaker 1: It really is. And unfortunately,
Democrats have not done a great job yet
of figuring out their way around this.
Speaker 2: Yeah, 100%. Thanks for the answer.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. There is Brian from
Ireland. Great to hear from you. We are taking
a very quick break. We're still taking calls,
so there's no need to hang up. Very
quick break and back right after this.